ciao a tutti allora esistono due tipi di
persone con le quali riescono
difficilmente avrete a che fare allora
come sto gli ipocriti sei bellissimo
uomo i sinceri fai schifo
i primi sono degli investimenti quali
sia sì cosa tu faccia una grandissima
figata anche se per loro rimane sempre
un evento [ __ ] che ballo preso 8 to
bravo sa i futuri ma è bravo continua
così allora ti sembro o mio dio stai
benissimo la puntura e serve lo come te
lo so stava bene saputo l'ultima società
mela che si e fatto un professore della
serie b ultimi fa pure schifo ma come
steve essa scioccanti a numeri pieni i
secondi se possibile sono ancora peggio
perché ti insultano direttamente ma sono
giustificati da una cosa che si chiama
sincerità ovvero appena finito di piace
no si indigni legame settimane dopo un
minimo del masso dell'ardo se tu senti
capperi sempre l'ultima cosa alla quale
vi preoccuperete generazioni alquanto
piacerebbe andare insieme ad ora a
correre lo vuoi capire che le gambe non
ce l'hai non ci avrei mai non lo puoi
fare fattela na ragione cavolo il che è
un po un problema perché l'ipocrita ti
risponderà sempre a non mica so stronza
che le dico che uno scaldabagno spento
mentre sincero lo penso alla verità
perché dovrei dirti una bugia perché di
vedere un po di tatto porca vacca si e
poi ci sono i peggio peggio delle due
categorie elencate prima che sono i
profondi padrona agli scarichi stadi per
cento
finisce nel cesso vado a restituire la
terra i doni che le ho rubato
vogliamo posso fare una domanda sì certo
alimenti perché c'è l'idea cioè quello
scopo
io non lo so così tanto per tanto per
vabbè mi diverto perché non va bene
no se si è che pensavo ci fosse magari
un messaggio una morale
no adobe campo bisogna morata che c'è
niente dai cosa che non capisco questa
ricerca di attenzioni non lo so mi
sembri cristo come come se fossi un
qualcosa di risolto non so non mi pare
senti pandev e realtà adesso non so voi
che tipo di esperienza abbiate avuto con
queste persone
fatto sta che le miss sono state pessime
un saluto
dottore dottore mi dimentico le cose
sedimenti delle cose che dimentico le
cose